(Arabber shouting)
- Arabbers carry fresh vegetables
and fruits around the city
in horse-drawn carts.
My grandfather's been
doing it all his life.
He 80-something years old now.
I've been doing it all my life,
and it's been around 50, maybe
a hundred years before me.
Here in Baltimore, you got markets around,
but you gotta have a
vehicle to get to 'em.
It's gonna cost 'em to get
there, cost 'em to get back.
So it's beneficial to a lot of people
for the Arabbers to be on the streets.
- Y'all have a good one.
Every morning, pull my wagon out,
I get all the fruit
together and design it up,
make it look nice.
And then I take the horse
and put him on the wagon
and I start on my day.
(bells jingling)
(Arabber shouting)
You mostly call out what
you got on your wagon.
We have oranges and apples.
- Peaches are awesome.
- When you come out and
you see an elderly person
just waiting at the door
for you to come through,
and they give you their little list.
That's a wonderful feeling.
Well, they depend on us and
we try to be there for 'em.
- Arabbers for life
baby, Arabbers for life.
- The kids, they love the horses,
and I want them to be able to see
that selling drugs ain't
the only way to make money.
This is what keep me out of trouble,
this is what feed my family,
this is what put food on the table,
pay the bills, pay the gas.
This is one of the
oldest things in the city
that's still going right now.
This is history.
- When I was a little kid,
it was nothing for me to turn a corner,
see an Arabber, one right
behind another sometimes.
If we don't get a lot of people behind us,
and expose the Arabbing business,
it might eventually die out.
But my dream is to see it last forever,
Till the day I shut my eyes for good.